foreign
on the very first day of my new career
yes as a bipper yes I decided to cancel
the podcast I'm gonna move to San
Francisco yes and I'm going to pays very
well yeah I'm just gonna play the odds
game I'm a bit everybody look for every
rental and hopefully I hit like a you
know a nice you know hopefully Draymond
slipping one day Draymond ain't gonna be
slipping obviously draymond's never
going to slip never yeah he's never
going to slip he's always ready for
action uh Draymond was at your uh
concert at the Roxy that's my brother
super nice guy yes great guy I saw him
out back and uh chopped it up with him
he did a video saying hi to my son yeah
um
so talk to me about your uh conference
have you talked to him since he knocked
out Jordan pool
ain't done with a little bit of
straightening yeah you know
I feel like families fight right Fringe
fight right things happen right you know
um and you know they just you know they
had to get some just get a little bit of
frustration though that's that's all it
was it wasn't nothing too crazy so how
bad does he want to be a Laker
I don't know you would have to go
he's your friend he's not my friend we
don't talk about those things I gotta
ask I don't ask because at your concert
he was sitting next to LeBron James and
his wife he loves it in L.A Jordan pool
wasn't at your concert you know kamingo
was in there you know Draymond and
LeBron were there yeah you know well if
that if that does happen right let's say
that does happen which I don't think it
will happen when that does happen let's
see I don't think it will I think he'll
be a lawyer you don't think that you're
just saying that because we're being
recorded I think he'll be a lawyer
you're full of [ __ ] let's say let's say
that does happen Okay okay how do you
see that working
I think if Russell Westbrook is gone
okay
and they give him like comparable salary
to what he's making now which I think is
like 27 million dollars yeah they could
probably afford to get another player
of
A.D and Draymond yeah
I'm not mad at it but the problem with
the Lakers is they still don't have
nobody who can shoot they don't have no
shooters
so it's like could we get Draymond and
Jordan pool I think he could push if you
push some Shooters I said we like I'm a
[ __ ] Laker fan I'm a LeBron you are a
Laker I'm not I'm a sunscreen I don't
like the Suns you just root for him
because you're from there no you're a
Laker fan listen bootleg Kev podcast no
no no I'm gonna tell you all what he
does I'm a LeBron let me tell y'all what
he does when he's not in Phoenix he
wears Lakers gear he goes to Lakers
games that's not true he celebrates
Lakers wins he just don't let y'all see
this [ __ ] because he got this Phoenix
monkey on his back he's a liar I'm
telling you the truth I've seen him in
this Suite with a LeBron James Laker
jersey on you haven't yes I have I've
never worn a LeBron Lakers jersey in my
life I'm probably making it up but I've
seen you in the suite rooting for the
Lakers I have um every LeBron Jersey in
my closet except the Lakers no I have
one so you see that Chuck he has the
[ __ ] Jersey but he wears the Jersey
to the games I've seen it I have it for
collection purposes yeah right I'm in
I'm I'm LeBron is like my my favorite
player ever okay so if you go into my
office I have like a LeBron toy so what
do you think your sons are going to do
this year because they lost you some
money last year
and a little bit of embarrassment
um I think it's gonna be rough it's
gonna be rough because DeAndre Aiden
don't want to be there Jay Crowders
trying to get the [ __ ] up out of there I
should have got KD we tried I don't
think he tried hard enough why you're
probably right we should have just said
whatever what do you want yeah give him
what he wants yeah he's the goat
hopefully by January 15th he's unhappy
there and ayton is tradable and then we
we we [ __ ] make the swap I'm a golden
state Laker so this the suns are not so
what that tells me is you are a Laker
fan growing up because of Kobe but then
the Warriors got good and you're like
it's convenient because I'm from the bay
let's go Warriors you were very close
you were very very close I know a lot of
people first the first half yes but it
was the We Believe Warriors team for me
with Baron Davis Matt Barnes Stephen
Jackson Michael Petrus yeah it was that
Jason Richardson it was that team was
Beatriz on that team the center the
white guy from I think he was yeah I
think he was on that team but that's
when I became a real Warriors fan so you
were a Warriors fan for like that run
and then they sucked again no but even
when they sucked Iraq so yeah early step
years early stiff then clay came
Draymond came yeah I remember me and Bam
went to the uh the a series when they
first went to the playoffs and played
the Spurs in the second round
I think it was around 2014 2015
somewhere around there but that's we
kind of started to see like okay the
Warriors
yeah when they first made it to the
second round that's when we kind of knew
like the words but Mark Jackson was a
coach yes sir and they got my boy out of
there and they brought him back since
yeah it's crazy he hasn't got another
job yeah I think he offended the wrong
people yes for the NBA's mildly racist
at least we know that's why he didn't
get hired by the Suns because the owner
was real I'm kidding the our coach is
black and so is our GM hey that doesn't
mean the owner can't be racist oh he's a
piece of [ __ ] and he's out of there I
hope Jeff Bezos buys the team they're
saying of Jeff Bezos by the team it's
going downhill what does that mean we
got the red we'll always be in the
luxury tax no you guys he'll be the
richest owner in the league by far just
living the luxury tax like y'all do you
guys will be flying spaceships to the
games I like it you know you'll you'll
just be two in the future to win